COLLEEN SHOGAN: Good afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
My name is Colleen Shogan and I'm the Deputy
Director of the National and International
Outreach at the Library.
I'm excited to welcome our audience inside
the historic Members Room of the Jefferson
Building here on Capitol Hill.
And I'm equally excited to welcome our virtual
audience joining us via live stream.
A video recording of this event will be made
available on our website.
March is Women's History Month and we're delighted
to celebrate it with our new boss, Carla Hayden,
who happens to be the first woman and the
first African American to assume this position
of Librarian of Congress.
[applause]
A few months ago, I noticed a lot of innovative
accomplishments have begun to happen at the
Library.
So, what had changed?
Well, you all know what had changed.
One woman and her leadership can make a world
of difference and today's panel is living
proof of that.
Before we start, I would like to thank the
Library of Congress' Office of EEO and Diversity
for making this program possible today.
Now, I'd like to briefly introduce our participants
before turning it over to Dr. Hayden for our
discussion.
Marin Alsop is the 12th musical director for
the Baltimore Symphony Orchestra.
She is the first woman to head a major American
orchestra and the only conductor to receive
the prestigious McArthur Fellowship.
In 2010, she was inducted into the Classical
Music Hall of Fame.
Previously, she was the first principal conductor
and then the musical director of the Colorado
Symphony Orchestra.
In addition to her numerous awards, she has
lead the Baltimore Symphony Orchestra in key
outreach initiatives, resulting in greater
youth musical awareness and appreciation.
A student of Leonard Bernstein, Alsop grew
up in New York City and is a graduate of Yale
University and Julliard.
Deborah Rutter is the third President of the
John F. Kennedy Center for the Performing
Arts.
She is the first woman to lead the center.
In her capacity as President, she is the Artistic
and Administrative Director of the Kennedy
Center, managing all aspects of the institution.
Prior to her current position, Ms. Rutter
served as President of the Chicago Symphony
Orchestra and Executive Director of the Seattle
Symphony.
Yo Yo Ma credits her for making the Chicago
Orchestra more accessible to a wider audience
through innovative educational programs and
community engagement, a model she is currently
replicating at the Kennedy Center.
A native of Pennsylvania and Los Angeles,
Rutter is a graduate of Stanford University
and holds an MBA from USC.
Molly Smith has served as the Artistic Director
of the Arena Stage since 1998.
She has lead the invention of the Arena Stage
with a vision of creating a national center
for American artists.
In 2010, the Washingtonian famously referred
to her as the unsinkable Molly Smith.
[laughter]
During her leadership, Arena has workshopped
more than 100 productions, produced 39 world
premieres, and developed 9 projects that have
headed to Broadway.
Before coming to Washington, Ms. Smith was
the Artistic Director of the Perseverance
Theater in Juneau, Alaska.
She has served as the literary advisor to
the Sundance Theater Lab and formed the Arena
Stage Writers Council, whose members are leading
American playwrights.
Ms. Smith is a graduate of Catholic University
and has a Master's Degree in Theater from
American University.
Our moderator today is Carla Hayden, the 14th
Librarian of Congress.
Please join me in welcoming these distinguished
women to
the Library of Congress.
[applause]
CARLA HAYDEN: I must tell you that I've been
the Librarian of Congress for 6 months and
I've had many many wonderful opportunities
to interact with many people, the collections
and things, but I have to tell you, this is
super special for me.
Because I have admired Marin for a long time.
I've gotten to be very jealous of Deborah
with that and that unsinkable Molly.
Wow.
So, it's wonderful to be with you and to have
what I hope will be an honest and engaging
discussion about being women in the arts in
particular but also in leadership positions.
When I was introduced as the first African
American, which is of course very significant
in many ways for me personally, but being
a woman in a feminized profession, where 85%
of the workforce is female and the top leadership
does not reflect that fact, is really significant
for my profession and has been talked about.
So, in my journey, I had the beginning, not
even knowing I was going to be the Librarian
- being an accidental librarian, I call it.
And I wondered how your journey started in
terms of the arts and then how did you make
that shift from being in the arts to arts
management and leadership.
When did that switch happen?
Molly?
MOLLY SMITH: Sure, sure.
Well, I was interested in arts and theater
from when I was a little girl and went to
Catholic school and thought I was going to
go into a pre-law degree.
And in the middle of traveling through Europe
at the age of 19 with a backpack on, I decided
I was going to chuck all that, follow my heart
and start a theater in Alaska, ok?
How crazy.
Everybody thought I was crazy.
So, in a sense, I moved from artist to administrator
right away, studied for the next 7 years to
make that happen and then drug 50 USC students
to Alaska to start the Perseverance Theater.
That's still alive and kicking now.
It's 38 years old and then about 19 years
ago, I came to Arena Stage.
So, I think I'm an artist whose always wanted
a home and often times when you want a home,
it also means that you combine the artistry
with management.
CARLA HAYDEN: Unsinkable.
DEBORAH RUTTER: Great name - Perseverance.
CARLA HAYDEN: And Deborah, you had an interesting
way of getting into management from art.
DEBORAH RUTTER: Well, actually I think mine
is very parallel.
As a young person, I was the beneficiary of
a time when there was music and art in schools.
So, in my public school, I had the opportunity
to become a violinist, literally.
My third grade teacher said, "which instrument
will you play?"
Not, "would you like to play, but will you
play?"
Played in orchestras and followed my heart.
Thought I was going to go off and get some
other job, not really knowing that there was
such a thing until I was in college and was
introduced through family friends to the field.
And had my first Summer job, my first real
summer job, I had other summer jobs.
My first real Summer job was at the Hollywood
bowl for the Los Angeles Philharmonic and
I decided there was this whole world of arts
management.
So, I took a pretty traditional course in
this way, but I would say that every decision
I made in my life was following my heart which
needed to follow music and I was never going
to be able to spend enough time in a practice
room to be doing what she does.
So, I get to support.
Basically what I do is to support what these
two people do.
CARLA HAYDEN: And that's great.
And violin?
MARIN ALSOP: I was a violinist of course,
but when I saw...
My dad took me to a young people's concert
when I was 9.
And I was getting in a lot of trouble playing
violin and trying to lead the orchestra from
the back of the violins at Julliard, pre college.
So, then, this guy came out to conduct who
was jumping around like a lunatic.
And I turned to my dad and said, "I could
be the conductor because nobody's yelling
at him."
I was 9 and that was Leonard Bernstein and
eventually he became my teacher and mentor.
And he was my hero for my entire life.
But, I think as a conductor and especially
as a woman, in a field where there were very
few women, you have to be an entrepreneur
because you don't have an instrument as a
conductor.
Unless you can coerce 20 or 30 people are
coming over every day to practice with you.
You don't have an instrument.
So, it's all about what you can put together
and the way I learned how to conduct was by
getting all of my friends together and creating
an orchestra.
So, I ran my own first orchestra and learned
hands on how to do marketing and build a board
and all those kinds of great things.
So, now I'm just a really annoying music director
because I know a little bit too much.
I don't know enough about management, but
I know more than I should.
[laughter]
You're just lucky you don't have me.
CARLA HAYDEN: Are there special challenges
for women in the arts in terms of pay equity,
discrimination?
Have you experienced that?
MARIN ALSOP: You know that's such a, from
my perspective, that's a question I'm asked
often, especially by journalists and I think
it's, I don't know the arts are such a difficult
field anyway.
It's really hard to ascertain which aspect
of what you're doing is causing some kind
of discrimination because there are so many
ways that you can run into obstacles.
And I really think that, I think that for
me, I think part of my success is never attributing
any of my difficulties or rejections to being
a woman.
I think that, instead, I always thought, "ok,
I have to be better.
Let me try to, how can I get something positive
out of this and learn from it and apply it
to what I'm doing?"
So, that's how I've reacted to it.
I don't know if you've had similar experiences.
DEBORAH RUTTER: What I would imagine for you
and is true certainly in my experience is
that there are preconceptions about what people
believe should happen.
You know, what will a woman wear on a podium?
What do women wear if they're a soloist playing
the violin or the piano or anything, the flute?
Whatever it is.
So, there are just gender expectations and
those expectations are one that we all have,
male and female.
MARIN ALSOP: Yes, that's true.
DEBORAH RUTTER: And that we all sort of have
to deal with and understand.
And those are the kinds of expectations that
are difficult to overcome.
Because if you don't fall in line, then there's
going to be a discussion, "well, she didn't
fall in line."
So, how many men have to buy gowns to do their
work?
I have to buy them.
People ask me, "what are you wearing tonight?"
When's the last time somebody asked a man,
what he was wearing to an event?
CARLA HAYDEN: Especially to a black tie event.
DEBORAH RUTTER: Exactly.
So, I think Marin's comment is right.
The arts is a different kind of business.
And so the interactions that we have with
our bosses, the interactions that we have
with our patrons, with our potential patrons
are all a little bit different.
But there's always this issue of how do people
treat women and men what the expectations
are I think that's the part that you are constantly
working to overcome.
MOLLY SMITH: There are pretty shocking statistics
in theater as far as men and women.
Of the major theaters in the United States
and there are 1800 theaters now that really
started by three intrepid women which really
included Zelda Fitch Handler of the Arena
Stage 70 years ago.
And there are large theaters and of the large
theaters and of the large theaters, only twenty
percent are run by women.
In terms of plays that are produced by these
1800 theaters, only 22% are written by women.
So, let that penny drop.
Start to look at that.
When you realize that that's happening at
the leadership level, that means it's happening
because boards are leaning more into male
candidates.
It means that headhunters perhaps have more
males who are headhunters.
It means that we have to do much more in terms
of mentorship of young women who are coming
up and support them.
In terms of changing the paradigm, it's a
paradigm shift.
I mean, I would agree with what everybody
else has said, but then I think there's the
other piece that just has to do with statistical
difficulties of what women face in terms of
leadership positions.
It is that you have to be better.
Wasn't it Flo Kennedy that said, "Fortunately,
that's not difficult"?
[laughter]
That was a very funny line, but it's complicated
and I think the idea of mentorship is so powerful.
Because it is the step in.
It is the door opening.
Even for me, more than education, it takes
you in a whole other direction because mentorship
is a one on one relationship that shows you
the path.
And I think without mentors for me like Joy
Zimmerman and Paula Vogel, who's a brilliant
playwright, I don't know if I would be here.
MARIN ALSOP: The statistics in classical music
are even more dire.
I think of our programming, is it 5% by women
composers?
It's really and I'm sure for conductors, it
ranges around there as well.
But, I would just jump in to say that I agree
so much about this concept about mentorship.
But also, I had a recent, if I can tell a
little anecdote.
I was conducting in Lucerne at the festival
this summer.
It's just I'm giving a master class for young
women conductors and an older woman in her
80s came and talked to me and someone said,
"Oh, do you know who she is?"
I said, "no, but she seems to know a lot about
conducting."
Well, her name is Sylvia Kaduf and I had never
heard her name and so I found out from someone
else that she was Bernstein's assistant in
1966 in the New York Philharmonic.
She was the first woman to win the Metropolis
competition, also the first woman to conduct
the Berlin Philharmonic.
And I had never heard of her.
I had never heard of her.
So, I went back to Lucerne two weeks ago with
a film crew I hired from Berlin and I'm making
a film about her.
And it was awesome to find her story, but
also this idea of how can we change the landscape?
If we don't do it- the three of us here, nobody's
going to do it.
So, for me that meant, for conducting, and
tell me if I talk too much, I might be there
already.
[laughter]
But, for conducting, you know for women, you
get one opportunity to conduct and you have
to remember that you haven't practiced with
your instrument before and all of the information
that you're trying to process and adapt to
and adjust to is so overwhelming and you have
only one chance, so you can't make a mistake.
And, you have to be able to make mistakes
in order to really achieve greatness, in my
opinion.
So, in 2002, I started a fellowship for women
conductors, young women conductors.
And I bring them around to orchestras I'm
conducting and they just do the opening piece.
So, it's not the pressure of the whole concert
on them and get some feedback from musicians
and from managers and things like that.
I have to say that of the 11 winners of the
fellowship, 4 or now American music directors,
5 are assistants with major orchestras, and
2 started their own orchestras.
So, I feel that you know, at least in a small
way, maybe by creating opportunities, but
this is to your point, that society isn't
accustomed to seeing women in these positions,
so we have to try to change that.
Even for me too.
Seeing women in certain roles, it's a little
jarring.
CARLA HAYDEN: It's jarring to normalize it,
to say that it's not anything unusual.
MARIN ALSOP: And we're predisposed to being
receptive to that.
CARLA HAYDEN: Right.
Deborah, are you doing some things in terms
of encouraging more diversity?
DEBORAH RUTTER: Well, a couple of different
things.
I wanted to say which is what I know about
the work that they do is that the level of
individual self-promotion has to be pretty
high.
And we who are the ones making the choices
along the way, have to be really open to it.
And it's really important for us to understand
that sometimes those behaviors of self-promotion
amongst, and this goes again to what is expected,
understood in different ways, is that a woman
being self-promoting, could be conceived as
aggressive.
Whereas a man doing that is just doing his
job, right?
So, there's always this sort of balance of
perception and there has to be the mentorship
and the open invitation.
Because as I think about it, it's really hard
sometimes to sort of cut through to see the
true gem that is there without the self-promotion.
So, it's one of those things that we have
to add to our tool kit in a way that feels
comfortable for us, but that for others can
receive it as well.
For us at the center and as a manager, and
administrator, in fact women are not the problem.
Sometimes we need to find more men to sit
around the table with us.
Because we are a mission driven institutions,
we are magnets for women who care about what
they're doing and women like me, who said,
"well I love to sing or I love to play the
cello, but I wasn't good enough, so I can
go and work there."
And at the center, we have countless dancers
and actors and people who are former somethings
who come and work.
So, internal for us, is not so much the issue
of gender, but it's really about the issue
of diversity background.
And this is something that is very important
to me and that we're working to really put
a focus on this.
And our HR team has a whole new diversity
and inclusion plan.
Most importantly, is that we're developing
something beyond the mentorship which is a
true fellowship program.
And that fellowship is about identifying future
arts administrators with diverse backgrounds,
diverse interests, and bringing them into
the center and really doing the same kind
of thing that you have done and sort of helping
give that extra boost, that extra lift.
MARIN ALSOP: But on the administrative side.
DEBORAH RUTTER: On the administrative, because
if you don't have, it works in both ways.
You know, if you don't have the leadership,
they don't have the vision, the perspective
to offer.
And so, this is about having a table of people
around which you put so many different voices
and making sure all of the voices are heard.
It's a big priority for us.
CARLA HAYDEN: That's great.
MOLLY SMITH: We have a fellows and internship
program at Arena Stage called the Alan Lee
Hughes Fellowship program that has been going
now for 25 years and it is for young people
from diverse backgrounds.
Over 700 people have been through it and because
we've just hit the 25th year, we went back
to find out how many people are still working
in the arts.
92%.
So, this is again, a one on one internship
program.
It's been going for a long time in every area
like theater management, artistic directing,
playwriting, just about every area, lighting
designer.
And our field now is rife with young people
that have come out of this program.
Also make sure because I believe every act
that we make in the arts is a political act.
Probably every act we make in our lives is
a political act because it's about choices,
right?
And so this year, seven out of our ten plays
are written by women or men of color because
I combine that in terms of what I see as far
as diversity and there are 8 plays directed
by women or men of color.
And I try and balance it on a yearly basis
because I think who you put on stage, those
are the voices that the audiences hear and
that's the way audiences start to change their
perspective of who is a leader and who isn't
a leader.
So, we just keep trying to right the balance
as far as the programming and the ideas we
put on stage.
MARIN ALSOP: From my perspective of course,
when I came to the Baltimore Symphony and
looking at the make-up of the orchestra on
stage, you know the Baltimore Symphony has
and still has one African American member
and how to change that, how to change that
make-up, I mean it's a long ranging vision
that one has to take.
You have to take, ok in my lifetime it may
not happen, but the reality is that the kids
aren't getting access to instruments young
enough in order to gain, first of all, the
interest and the skill to audition for an
orchestra at this level.
So, that's when I approached my musicians
and said, "listen, why don't we mentor one
kid in the neighborhood."
That didn't go so well, but the idea, the
idea developed into a program where we started
with 30 kindergarten kids in 2008 and today
we have almost 1500 kids playing instruments
and there are 17 are now at the high school
for performing arts, they've been accepted
because they are now getting old enough to
get to high school age.
But, you know, how long it will take for a
program like Orch Kids and for some other
programs that have come up to impact our major
orchestras and our major stages, who knows?
But if we don't start, you know that's the
point, right?
And also it affects our audiences.
Now all of these kids and their parents are
big classical music fans.
CARLA HAYDEN: Because they attend the performances
because of their children.
So, that gets to what Deborah you mentioned,
there are very few arts programs now in schools.
So, isn't that a big challenge in terms of
looking at your future audiences?
Your future?
DEBORAH RUTTER: Well I could talk for the
next three hours on this topic.
CARLA HAYDEN: We're going to open it up for
question and answer in a minute.
DEBORAH RUTTER: You know, I most recently
lived in Chicago and what was really interesting
was the northern suburbs had fantastic music
programs because the school districts in that
area were wealthy enough and had leadership
and input from family enough that they had
really great programs.
It was the schools in the city and on the
Southside that were suffering the most from
this.
And the tragedy of this is that the programs
around any kind of art, whether its dance
or theater or music are what keep kids in
school, keep them focused, get them really
engaged with being successful.
And so this is not so much a strategy for
building audiences for our theaters of the
future at all.
I am here because of my third grade teacher.
Yes, my family cared about it and still do,
but my teachers were the most important people
in my life who brought me to this place.
And there's increasing scientific knowledge
that supports the idea that being engaged
with the arts helps with brain development
which then of course, leads to school success.
So, this really is a campaign that is so much
not about arts organizations, but people who
care about what it can do for young people.
And that's my not so secret goal is to have
every child be able to have access to arts
education.
So Orch Kids is the perfect example of this.
MARIN ALSOP: But, we see the kids.
We don't have the kind of funding to study
it in depth, but anecdotally, I see the kids
growing, I see them developing, I see them
skills that they can apply to any discipline
they select.
And the goal isn't to make them all classical
musicians although I wouldn't mind that of
course.
But, the goal really is in 20 years when I
go to the doctor and she says, "oh yeah.
I remember you.
I was an Orch Kid."
Or the mayor or the leaders of our community
because the important skills you develop are
the ones you need in every field.
CARLA HAYDEN: It's called a discipline for
a reason.
DEBORAH RUTTER: It's about creativity, it's
about collaboration, innovation.
These are all skills for future workforce.
MARIN ALSOP: And it's how they all feel about
themselves also.
I remember in math, you're either right or
wrong - it's a 50/50.
But, if you play a violin, you're always right,
let me tell you.
[laughter]
In my house maybe.
DEBORAH RUTTER: There's a great example in
Chicago today, the Kenwood Academy which has
a really beautiful jazz program that has been
built and nurtured by someone who really loved
the school and the program there.
And with just a little bit of an extra boost
and attention, the school and the children
are so much more successful as a result of
this.
We did a project with them in Chicago and
Jason Moran, our artistic director for Jazz,
loved it so much that he reprised it and reprised
it and changed it based on his relationship
with these kids and brought it 3 years later,
so it was the next generation of high school
jazz band, to Washington to perform with him.
And what this does for these children on the
Southside of Chicago is so powerful.
CARLA HAYDEN: I know about Kenwood on the
Southside of Chicago.
And the theater part and getting them involved.
MOLLY SMITH: My biggest fear of losing the
arts in school is that we lose innovation
in every field.
That's our number one power, I think, as like
our American energy, that kind of entrepreneurship.
Because what the arts teach you, has to do
with teamwork, ideas, imagination.
You know, the greatest freedom we have is
our imagination.
And I don't think we are taught it in the
same way in the sciences, so that's why I
keep arguing for not STEM but STEAM.
Let's put the power in it as well.
So, we reach about 20,000 young people at
Arena Stage every year.
But, the one program I'd like to talk about
it is the "Voices of Now" which is ten different
groups of young people who developed stories
from their lives over a 9 month period of
time and then they are all produced at Arena
Stage and end up touring in different places
as well.
Now, anecdotally, we have a lot of information
about what happens to the young people after
this program, how many of them go on to college,
how many of them go on to graduate school,
how many of them go on to great careers.
Again, it's fantastic.
That one on one relationship changes a young
person's life and so fighting for programming
in the schools, I think is very important
because what's happened, basically around
the country is theaters and arts organizations
have taken up that banner and we're doing
the arts programs within our own organization.
CARLA HAYDEN: What about teacher education?
Helping teachers who might not have a formal
arts program do something?
DEBORAH RUTTER: Well, this is a big issue
because of course, so much needs to be done
in the primary classroom and those teachers
are not experts.
So, teaching artists are really critically
important and teaching artists are, come in
by contract to a school and they stand side
by side with a classroom teacher to help augment
that training that happens.
We, at the center have a pretty significant
one that we do in various parts of the country
and we understand that teacher training is
really vital.
We work with teaching artists as well.
A program that we just brought on last fall
is called, "Turnaround Arts."
It started out at the President's Committee
for arts and humanities and Michelle Obama
was sort of the champion for this program.
And it was about using the arts to help turn
a low performing school into a higher performing
school.
So, it was beyond teaching arts education.
It was integrating art into the daily lives.
So, you learn multiplication tables by singing
or you would learn history by creating a play
or acting.
And so we're in about 60, I think it's 60,
I keep inflating and I don't want to over
inflate yet, but we're in a whole lot of low
performing schools across the country.
I've only had it in the program for about
6 months now, so.
But, it's a very exciting program because
we work by providing resources to the school,
teaching artists into the school, training
for the school, the school as a whole, not
just certain, in the classroom teachers.
And then we pair them with celebrity artists
who actually make a point of going to the
school multiple times in a year to draw attention
to the school and build morale for it.
Bit, it's fascinating because it's a different
approach that we as arts administrators have
had because when arts programming started
getting cut 40 years ago or more, even longer
than that.
We as arts institutions first got angry and
frustrated and kept saying, "well, it's the
school's responsibility, it's the government's
responsibility and we didn't at that time
go in and say, "lets partner."
Now we have to partner because otherwise it
won't exist at all.
So, sometimes our organizations are the only
ones providing that.
But, we are trying with Turnaround Arts, to
demonstrate that the use of the arts can actually
help improve a school.
And through that case and getting the research
to support it, then we might be able to have
a larger impact.
CARLA HAYDEN: Haven't you been able to attract,
I know withy Orch Kids, philanthropy?
Arts philanthropy has increased.
MARIN ALSOP: Yeah, of course.
I think that.
Well, there are a few things I'd love to say.
Something that is on my mind at least at the
moment is that I hope that the small amount
of government support for the arts that we
now currently have, that everyone speaks out
to preserve the National Endowment for the
Arts.
It's a very very small token support of the
arts, but I think it's very important that
we insist that our leadership in the United
States of America, at least advocates for
the arts in some small measure.
I mean, I work as musical director also in
Brazil at the Sao Paolo Symphony and I have
to say for Brazil where everything's in chaos
constantly there.
Yet, the leadership of the country believes
that art is a vehicle to promote tolerance
and peace among people and so even when things
are cut, the arts are cut proportionally,
not disproportionally.
And that gives me pause to think that here
in South America, there in South America,
they could have this kind of visionary leadership,
whereas here in the United States where it's
so integral to who we are, I believe as Americans,
it's all about the individual, the creative
power of entrepreneurship and that's what
we're all about, sort of fundamentally and
yet we're not supporting that.
It's not about the arts.
You know, we make it sort of a siloed experience.
It's about creating people who are well balanced
and who have a vision.
I can think outside the box.
Maybe that's the biggest thing the arts give
you.
You know, whether you ever go into the arts
or not.
And of course it's always a struggle in the
United States because we have to, we have
to build support- philanthropic support on
every level.
It's not just that you have a good idea, but
then you have to fund it and then you have
to measure it.
That's the part I struggle with.
Everything has to be measured here.
CARLA HAYDEN: Yes, what are the results?
MARIN ALSOP: Can we have the data?
CARLA HYDEN: For the full human being.
How about that?
MARIN ALSOP: Yeah really.
Maybe just shake the kid's hand.
DEBORAH RUTTER: I have stood side by side
with this issue and the argument about data
for a long time and have come to believe that
sometimes if you can demonstrate what really
happened.
We certainly count the number of people who
have attended performances.
We are counting the number of women enrolled
etcetera etcetera.
If we can see what the impact is.
The issue really is, we are always living
on a shoestring.
Because you always want to put more money
into the art, you don't really want to put
money into the things around it that might
support it in the long term.
So, this issue of doing research and evaluation
and keeping track of it is one that we in
our field have really not done a great job
and as I've come to the Kennedy Center, we
do more of for exactly the reasons that we've
been talking about.
MARIN ALSOP: Well, you have that mandate.
Do you find though, I think we've done a very
poor job also of educating the public as to
the financial benefit of arts.
You know, for every dollar spent in the arts,
it exponentially reaps results that are exponential
to the investment and we haven't done a good
job of publicizing that and getting the message
out to the public I don't think.
CARLA HAYDEN: That seems like it would be
very strong with the public.
DEBORAH RUTTER: Well, just earlier this week,
Darren at the Americans for the Arts program,
Bob Lynch spoke about the fact that 145 million
dollars of the NEA is worth some huge magnitude
like 800 billion dollars.
Not million, but billion dollars of economic
impact and so we're not, this is not a trivial
thing, what we're standing up for.
If you can track what happens to a young person
who's involved with the arts and where they
go, whether and how the arts have influenced
them, I think that can be something that is
really important for us to be looking at.
I think the Americans for the Arts are doing
more of it, but we need to do it more as individual
institutions.
MOLLY SMITH: When Arena made the decision
to stay in Southwest Washington and rebuild,
that whole program and the new Arena Stage
really became a catalyst for building in Southwest
Washington, which has been seen as the forgotten
quadrant.
There are now 36 different developments that
are happening there.
If you drive down in Southwest, you'll probably
see 15 cranes in the air.
Now, would that have happened without Arena?
Probably in about 15 or 20 years.
Did it get pushed by Arena?
Yes.
And we see that happening in communities all
over Washington DC and indeed all over the
country.
The arts are real drivers of economic expansion.
My fear about the loss of the NEA, the loss
of the NEH, the loss of all of our cultural
programs, is what is really going to happen
in smaller rural areas as well as in cities.
Because for smaller rural areas, that often
is the only money that they have to have the
school program which is teaching young people
how to do puppetry or teaching young people
how to make plays.
That's it.
You know, you go out to some place like Kotzebue
in Alaska and is that whole program going
to be cut?
So, that really changes the equation.
It's a narrowing of vision about the beauty
of who we are as Americans.
And that's what I think the attack is and
that's why I think it's so important for all
of us to get out pen and paper and write our
legislators and let people know because we
know pressure works.
It works.
[applause]
CARLA HAYDEN: I Just got my time sign that
we're going to open it up for a little Q and
A. But, I just wanted to do a little inside
scoop thing here.
You can break some news.
Do you have anything that you can share with
us that's coming up?
This is YouTube, Facebook...
MOLLY SMITH: This is what we don't want anybody
else to know accept for the room, right?
CARLA HAYDEN: Of course.
Some upcoming projects that might be interesting.
You mentioned Lorraine Hansberry is coming.
MOLLY SMITH: Yeah.
Raisin in the Sun is coming to Arena Stage.
But, I wanted to mention "Sovereignty" that's
coming to Arena next year.
This is part of our "Power Plays" initiative.
We have 25 new plays and musicals that are
being commissioned by Arena Stage for each
decade beginning in 1776 to the present decade.
We've already commissioned 9 people.
And one of them is Mary Katherine Nagle, native
American lawyer, activist lawyer, wonderful
playwright.
Her play is "Sovereignty."
It takes place both in 1830 with Andrew Jackson
and broken treaties and present day broken
treaties between the Cherokee nation and also
the United States government.
This is a story that hasn't been told and
that's one of the things that I love to do
in the theater.
CARLA HAYDEN: Wow.
Deborah?
DEBORAH RUTTER: Well, you know as we sit in
this really amazing building and this beautiful
room, it seems as though many people know
so much about the history of our city, our
country, and the buildings in Washington,
DC.
But even I didn't own it the same way that
I do now.
Which is that the Kennedy Center is the living
memorial to John F Kennedy.
There is no other memorial.
There is a library and all of that, but this
is the memorial to John F Kennedy and you
know, a lot of people didn't really...
I knew it, but I didn't know it to live it.
And so, as we are on the countdown to what
would have been his 100th birthday on May
29 of this year, we are really thinking about
our identity as it relates to both being a
performing arts center and the living memorial
to JFK.
And we're having just an extraordinary season
full of programming that's so easy to attribute
to things that he stood for because not only
did he and his wife care so much about the
arts and humanities, but the other things
that we attribute to him- courage, freedom,
justice.
There's one...
Freedom, courage, justice, and gratitude.
And we are building all of our programming
around it and there's sort of a culminating
week of activities at the Center.
All this has been announced, so it's not new
news.
CARLA HAYDEN: Oh shoot.
[laughter]
DEBORAH RUTTER: Other than the fact that,
I don't know if everyone is paying attention
to it in quite the same way.
We're bringing back open house.
We're going to have a day of celebration for
JFK and it's really been affirming to have
such a generous, articulate, inspiring man
to be the namesake of our space and I'm actually
looking forward to an effort that will sort
of revitalize the memorial aspect itself,
so that the Center will be a must visit location
the way the Library of Congress...
CARLA HAYDEN: We're working on that.
DEBORAH RUTTER: is a must visit location for
all who visit our nation's capital.
CARLA HAYDEN: We're working on that.
I'll explain a little later.
MARIN ALSOP: Well, I don't have any big secrets.
CARLA HAYDEN: Oh Marin.
MARIN ALSOP: I know, it's terrible.
But, for those of you who don't know the Baltimore
Symphony, all I can say is we're sort of the,
we're the poor cousin up the road.
But, the quality of our orchestra and the
level of passion and commitment from the musicians
and the Baltimore Symphony, I think is really
unparalleled in the United States.
I think it's one of the great, one of the
really great orchestras of the world.
And I'd invite you to come and hear the orchestra
any time and it's nice as we're ramping up,
also to 2018 which is the 100 anniversary
of Leonard Bernstein.
And so, it's nice because we have that connection
also with the Kennedy Center because Bernstein
wrote his mass in honor of JFK, so there's
always that nice, that nice connection.
And of course Bernstein inspired so many people
and as I said to start, was my hero, so we'll
be doing a lot of programming around that
of course.
CARLA HAYDEN: Well, I was saying and I said
I'll mention it later, but the Library of
Congress is connecting to all of you.
We have his papers.
We're going to be part of the celebration.
Lorraine Hansberry, Lee Strasburg archives,
so we will be supplementing, complementing,
and will be part of what you do.
And the Orch Kids are coming.
MARIN ALSOP: The Orch Kids are going to come
and play here.
CARLA HAYDEN: Right her in the Great Hall.
So, we are just delighted.
[applause]
So, we'd like to open it up for questions
or comments and things you have.
Talk about Women's History Month.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Well, first of all thank
you very much for your very candid comments.
In the course of the discussion up there,
the term, leadership was used at least several
dozen times.
So, and we have 4 very distinguished women
up there who have achieved significant leadership
positions in their chosen professional path.
So, my question is, can you talk a little
more about your personal leadership style
and maybe a lesson or two about leadership
that you learned as you developed into a leader?
CARLA HAYDEN: I'm looking at you guys first.
DEBORAH RUTTER: Well, that's a really good
question.
I will start only because these two have more
creative answers than I do.
But, I do think that that's why there has
been an increasing number of women in managerial
positions in the arts.
And it's because I am a consensus builder
and I work on building teams.
I'm not an autocrat who says, "this is the
way it's going to be.
This is what I care about.
This is only what we are going to do."
And in fact, whenever I have a group of colleagues
who ask for that direction, I push back even
harder.
I push my seat away from the table and I say,
"no, we are doing this together."
Building that team who believe in where we're
going and how we're going to get there and
that's the most rewarding aspect of it.
Now, you go to a different city and you find
a new culture when you go into that organization
and sometimes it takes a while to change from
one style to another.
And I have never inherited a job from another
woman, so I build a different kind of an atmosphere
in the organization and it's much more fun
and you get so much more done and there are
so many more creative ideas that come out
of your institution when you can lead by building
a team who all have a common vision.
MOLLY SMITH: And I would say the most important
part of leadership is communication.
Because the worst thing in the world is to
be a leader leading the band and there's no
one behind you.
And so it's all about communicating whatever
the particular vision is, whatever the particular
idea is.
And also recognizing that sometimes it take
a lot of time to make whatever that dream
or that vision come true.
When I came to Arena, I re-focused Arena on
American plays, American ideas and American
artists.
It had been much more of an international
company and American work before that time.
It took 8 or 9 years to do that in a full
way.
And it's really insuring that everybody who
is at the theater leads in their own way because
people want to lead and people need to lead.
They're their own experts.
So, giving people the power to be able to
do that, I think is incredibly important in
leadership roles.
MARIN ALSOP: Well, I agree with everything
you're saying.
I think that being a good leader is being
a very good listener.
I think collaborative leadership, trying to
nurture collaboration.
But, I think at the end of the day as a leader,
you have to accept accountability, especially
in an orchestra.
It can't be a democracy.
And so, ultimately, even though a lot of people
would like it to be.
I think ultimately, from my perspective, just
a personal mantra is "I'd much rather be respected
than liked."
And often if they respect you long enough,
they end up liking you.
That can't be one's motivation.
I think sometimes leaders have to make the
hard decisions and stand alone for the good
of the art.
And if you always put your art first, you
can't go wrong.
CARLA HAYDEN: That's wonderful.
Just on a side note, as a leader and as a
woman, making sure that there's a safety net
for making mistakes and that you as a leader
can reveal that you make mistakes, that you
do things and it's ok.
Creating that safety net.
Another one.
And wasn't it funny how I said, "You guys."?
[laughter]
As soon as I said it, I said, "ok, Women's
History Month."
AUDIENCE MEMBER: I applaud each of you and
I hear a lot about children and I am a substitute
teacher and an artist and a senior citizen.
And what I want to know is, where do you see
our place in the arts?
As I hold up my card as being a senior citizen.
CARLA HAYDEN: Well, I just told Marin about
a lady who she knew, Netty Taylor, who just
passed away recently at 102 and her greatest
joy was bringing young people to the BSO,
the Baltimore Symphony Orchestra and being
that person, even with the wheel chair, everything.
Netty Taylor would sit there and make sure
that she was part of that.
MARIN ALSOP: So, don't you think we could
do a lot more with seniors and getting them
involved?
Especially...
One of my dreams is for our Orch Kids program
is to offer our retired musicians who have
this unbelievable wealth of knowledge, a post-orchestra
career working with the Orch Kids and putting
a whole training program into place.
I think that when I look at many of our volunteers,
are older people who are involved with the
kids and they're so devoted and dedicated.
And they also come with this lifetime of experience
and knowledge.
So, I think we can offer more because I think
it's a resource that we're not taking advantage
of as we could.
DEBORAH RUTTER: You know, if you think about
the work that's often done by corporations,
sort of searching after the 18 to 24 year
old.
And I have spent all of my career sort of
scratching my head about why are we always
talking about wanting younger audiences?
Part of the reason we're looking for younger
audiences is because we're all aging and we're
all aging into being seniors and we're all
aging into that time in our life when we actually
have more time to do other things.
We need to make sure that you have young people
coming in.
And it's about making the connection throughout
life, whether it is the youngest person to
the senior or seniors then helping young people
come into the arts and having that experience.
And I think that as I experience with my own
family and with my own organization, we're
thinking more about the programs that we're
offering to audiences of all ages and understanding
in fact that music and dance and theater can
be even more important as you age and it's
not just because you have more time, but actually
it is a part of what happens in your whole
physical cycle and your brain and keeping
yourself healthy.
So, this is actually something that I've been
thinking about, not at a fully formed idea
yet, but other than the fact that I see that
some of the most active people in my life
both at work and at home, are the ones who
are working and active and engaged still.
And those are the ones who are docents and
helping out as teaching assistants for our
education programs.
But, I've really come to think that developing
some programs that are sort of health and
wellness programs for people of all ages and
seniors in particular, would be something
that would be a great way for us to benefit
from.
But, this is also something that we don't
always know a lot about because we're dealing
with...
We're our own age, we're thinking about bringing
young people in.
So, it's an area that I think as our population
ages, as there's a larger population that
is of a different age, we can think about
the role that we are, in terms of providing
services, whether active participatory ones
or as patrons.
So, it's a wonderful question and it's one
that happens to be sort of resonant for me
right now as we are doing some work.
Actually, I will tell you a secret which is
that we're doing a program that hasn't really
been out there too much yet with the National
Institutes of Health.
And it's around health and wellness and music
and the brain and we're looking at how music
has an impact on young kids and what it can
do for music therapy.
We talked about that and then all the way
through creative aging.
So, it's something that is really on the top
of mind right now.
CARLA HAYDEN: Creative aging.
DEBORAH RUTTER: Creative aging.
Think about it.
CARLA HAYDEN: I think we need that.
Another question.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Hi.
I work here at the Library and if I had more
time, I'd talk about the author named Marguerite
De Angeli that influenced both Dr. Hayden
and actually me in going into a career writing
about Quakers, which is just an aside to say
I ended up getting a PhD in American Studies.
But, had you asked me at the same age about
10 or 12 years old who I wanted to be when
I grew up, it would have been Leonard Bernstein.
Bernsteen.
Bernstein.
MARIN ALSOP: Bernstein, your right.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Bernstein.
Sorry, my cousins are Bernsteen, he's Bernstein.
And the height of my conducting career was
to conduct the high school orchestra for one
piece in my senior year.
My question is about talent in the arts or
the idea of talent which I think as I look
back, I don't know how much talent I did or
didn't have, but at a certain point, it didn't
seem to me that I had the talent to be an
orchestral conductor and I went in other directions.
I also play the violin, by the way.
But, I think that at the time, there were
senses of role models for women in those ways
and I heard you all talk about mentorship.
But, I don't actually know the answer for
where talent versus- so it's a nature nurture
kind of question I guess.
If you can talk about that a little more because
it's a big deal in the arts.
It seems to me.
CARLA HAYDEN: And before you start, I'm laughing
because I'm the product of two classically
trained musicians and I'm sitting here as
a librarian.
So, that tells you my talent and why this
is so important.
A violinist and a pianist, so talent does...
MARIN ALSOP: I don't know.
Maybe I have some very idealistic view of
talent.
I think, also I think the word, creativity
is often restricted to people who have chosen
the arts as their discipline.
Whereas, I think that creativity is inherent
in being human.
When people tell me they're tone deaf or something
like that, I think that's simply not possible.
You know someone told you that and you started
taking that on.
Or you can't draw.
I was told, "you're terrible at that," so
I always thought, "I have no talent for that."
But, instead if someone had said, "well, let's
see.
Let me help you a little bit.
Oh that's nice."
It's all about mentorship I think and encouragement.
The thing I like about the Orch Kids program,
it's not targeting talented kids.
It's democratic.
I believe everyone is talented.
I believe that had that been a passion for
you and someone had encouraged you, you could
do what I'm doing now.
For me, it's all about opportunity and exposure
and every kid I find...
I became a parent very late in life.
I was amazed at what my kid could do, but
it was only because I had... my expectations
were this high.
So, when I started with the Orch Kids, my
expectations were also this high and then
immediately, the kids go to wherever you put
the bar and higher.
I think every child is born with enormous
talent and genius and we just gradually suck
it out of them.
(laughter) And that's what we can't afford
to do.
So, maybe I'm very idealistic about this,
but I believe you have the talent that I have.
DEBORAH RUTTER: I have a couple of different
stories of circumstances where a really influential
teacher or conductor would actually say to
and gave examples where hard work is actually
more important than talent.
Because somebody who has raw talent may coast
without the hard work.
So, the people who we see as genius are using
raw talent and then working really hard at
it.
And so that's why I would always encourage
to stick with it.
My problem was I didn't want to be alone in
a practice room.
MARIN ALSOP: Right.
It's whether you have the personality to endure
it.
I think.
DEBORAH RUTTER: Exactly.
Exactly.
But, I love it like crazy and I dedicate enormous
amounts of my time in a different way really
supporting it and experiencing it.
So, it's really about how you spend your time.
So, absolutely, you could have been a conductor.
There's a long path to travel, but.
MOLLY SMITH: And I would totally agree.
I think that there's like 5 or 10 % talent
because everybody has talent and the rest
of it is perseverance, persistence, gutsiness,
aggressive, pushing through all of the rejection
and being able to say, "no, I can still do
this."
But, that also has to do with self-image,
you know?
The people around you supporting you, saying,
"You can do it.
You can do it."
And that's one of the most important things
that we can give to young people and adults
as well because I believe in lifelong education,
that curiosity is through an entire life.
And even if you don't think you have the talent
to do this thing, just try.
Just try.
Go out and do it.
It's amazing what it will open up.
CARLA HAYDEN: And to be able to recognize
it and that's sometimes the part that's really
gripping when you know that young people might
not have the opportunity to have their particular
talent recognized at an early enough stage.
Maybe you're not good at drawing, but there's
a child over there that's singing all the
time.
This one is doing that.
The greatest gift my parents gave me was at
12 we all agreed that when they looked at
musical notes, they heard music and when I
looked at text, I heard words.
And that was ok.
And then I went off with words and appreciated
it.
But, to know.
Sometimes you drive in neighborhoods and you
look on corners and you see people and you
say wow, when did the light go out in their
eyes?
When was that 4 year old not given that chance
to do that and here they are.
DEBORAH RUTTER: That's the spiral that is
so difficult.
That if you get into that, if you are caught
somewhere in that spiral and you don't have
the network that can give it to you.
So, it has to come from teachers, it has to
come from community leaders, it has to come
from somebody if it can't come from your parents
and mentors.
And that's why we have to have a network that
supports people.
CARLA HAYDEN: Right.
I think we have time for one more question
or comment and to really in this celebration
of Women's History Month, I can't thank you
all enough.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: I wanted to echo everyone
else and just saying thank you all so much
for coming out and sharing your experiences
for this event.
My question is as women of power, how do you
all weave the concept of intersectionality
into your organizations in regard to hiring
or promoting or just generally creating a
pipeline so that arts leadership may be more
inclusive to women of color?
DEBORAH RUTTER: Well, first of all you have
to have, you have to be very explicit in saying
this is a priority and having broad ownership,
because if just one person owns it, it won't,
it can't succeed.
But, if you can get broad ownership throughout
your institution.
In my case, it was extremely helpful that
the board was right there with me.
If not perhaps ahead of me when I came to
the Center and therefore putting the structure
in place.
It does though mean that you have to put mandates
And so for us now, there can never be a final
candidate pool that doesn't have diversity
in the pool.
And a conversation that always takes place
both from the hiring people.
Now I'm lucky because I have an institution
that has really great reach and I want to
use the size and the reach of this institution
to help build as many future leaders as possible.
But, I believe it can happen in any kind of
organization.
It has to be something that you believe as
a core value.
And you have to have the whole team doing
the same thing.
Because the one person isn't doing all of
the hiring.
There are a lot of people doing the hiring,
but I think that Molly's given a great description
because there are jobs everywhere.
It's not just in sort of the administrative
aspect of it.
There are jobs throughout our buildings that
are supporting the arts and are a way into
our organization
MARIN ALSOP: We're looking also to trying
to create diversity on our board of directors.
I'm sure everyone, the good thing is that
it's an open conversation now and I think
there is an awareness of the dearth of diversity
throughout our field.
So, I think that's exciting because people
are willing to have the conversation and really
try to at least change the landscape to a
certain degree.
MOLLY SMITH: We look at it holistically at
Arena Stage.
When I came to Arena, our audience was not
diverse so I walked the streets of Washington,
DC.
I went into the churches in Washington, DC.
I went into some of the Baptist churches and
of course Washington DC is a black and white
city.
And there was programming that we had on stage
that really focused on the African American
experience, but our audiences didn't reflect
that.
And this is unusual because Arena started
as the first integrated theater in Washington,
DC 68 years ago.
And so it's in our bloodlines, the importance
of this.
And so I realized it all happens through programming
and so about a third to half of the work that
we do every year is around people of color.
When I was in the Baptist churches, I saw
the way in which people welcomed people is
they would stand outside the door and shake
hands with people all the way into the church.
So, we changed our usher structure.
So, there are people all the way through the
theater saying, "welcome, come in."
We have people all the way outside because
theaters tend to be places where people are
a little bit nervous coming in.
And so eventually, now almost 30% of our audience
are people of color.
That's one of the most diverse in the United
States - one of the top ones in theaters.
And that's something that we work on on a
daily basis.
Our staff is diverse.
Our programming is diverse.
Our board is becoming more diverse.
We have a wonderful chairman, Judith Batty
who's African American.
And we just keep working at it and as you
said Marin, it's moment by moment, it's day
by day.
It's doing exactly what Deborah says, which
is when we have a pool of people, what we're
looking at for a particular position, there
has to be a person of color within that pool
who can get the job, right?
It can't just be, "well, we can't find anybody."
Go out again, keep looking.
And so that's where we as administrators need
to keep our own feet in the fire.
CARLA HAYDEN: I can't thank you all enough
because even though, and all of you that are
here today, because this is Women's History
Month, but women's history is all year round.
And I just thank you so much.
DEBORAH RUTTER: We're so proud of you, Carla.
[applause]